[Music]
Brianna Taylor would have been 27 years
old on June 5th had she not been killed
in her own home
when Louisville police officers made a
late night raid on the wrong address
looking for someone who had been taken
into police custody hours earlier she
was shot eight times and no arrests have
been made now some of the biggest stars
in Hollywood are paying tribute to
Brianna on what would have been her 27th
birthday cardi B took to Twitter writing
that Brianna's story is so sad and
unfair adding the fight ain't over til
you get justice Selena Gomez pointed
that she and Brianna would have been the
same age before urging her followers on
Twitter to sign a petition demanding
that charges be filed against the
officers involved Emmy Rossum Sara
Bareilles Kerry Washington niecy Nash
Jeffrey star and Ellen DeGeneres also
tweeted their support on Taylor's
birthday for those of you at home
looking for ways to pay tribute to
Brianna Taylor here's how number one say
her name continue to say Brianna
Taylor's name whether that's protesting
in the street or on social media and on
Friday
use the hashtag say her name and
birthday for Brianna to share tributes
artwork and calls to action number two
send a letter join in the birthday card
Drive mailing letters to the Attorney
General and the Louisville Metro mayor
at these addresses demanding the
officers responsible for Taylor's death
get charged you can also email the
Attorney General and Mayor number three
sign a petition the easiest way to lend
your voice is to sign the justice for
Brianna Taylor petition which in part
calls for charges to be filed and the
arrests of the officers involved
immediately you can also text enough to
five five one five six number four
donate you can donate directly to
Brianna's family through a verified
GoFundMe and you can also donate to the
Louisville community bail fund which
serves protestors on the ground in
Louisville as they fight for justice for
Taylor and to bring an end to police
brutality and systemic racism
[Music]